[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur LCP et
Public Sénat bonsoir Tam bonsoir
Brigitte bonsoir à tous nous sommes
réunis pour une émission spéciale
consacrée à la commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi
immigration députés et sénateurs sont
réunis depuis 6h maintenant à
l'Assemblée nationale pour tenter de
trouver un accord sur le texte et bien
il n'y a aucune fumée blanche pour le
moment aucun consensus n'a pu être
dégagé et notamment car à peu après 17h
les travaux de la commission ont été
suspendus pendant 4 heur d'affilé en
cause bien les aides au logement qui
font l'objet d'un vif désaccord entre la
majorité présidentielle et la majorité
sénatoriale entre Renaissance et LR
alors on va revenir bien évidemment sur
les négociations autour de ce projet de
loi immigration avec nos invités et puis
nous serons aussi en duplexe de la salle
des quatre colonnes avec Elsa monagava
Stéphanie des pierres et Quentin Calmet
et avec nous pour cette émission
François Cormier bouligon bonsoir vous
êtes député renaissance du Cher et
Pierre-Henri dumonde bienvenue à vous
vous êtes députés les républicains du
pas decalis également avec nous Laur
Lavallette bonsoir bonsoir député
rassemblement national du Var et Yanne
brossa bonsoir bonsoir sénateur
communiste de Paris et suppléant dans
cette commission mixte paritaire
allez on part tout de suite à
l'assemblée nationale où se trouve Elsa
mondingava Elsa vous êtes salle des
quatre colonnes alors après 4 heur de de
suspension peu après le début des
travaux un peu après 17h et bien les
débats ont repris les discussions ont
repris à 21h où on en est actuellement
et bien à côté on est toujours à
l'article 1 Brigitte et on en arrive au
sujet sensible on le développera plus
longuement celui de la question des aPL
et des conditions de résidence pour que
les étrangers puissent les troucher
regardez dans cette salle des quatre
colonnes il y a encore beaucoup de
journalistes qui attendent vous l'avez
dit cette commission mixte paritaire
elle a repris à 21h avec cette fois de
vraies discussions puisque quand elle a
commencé à 17h elle a été suspendue
quasiment immédiatement déc
conciliabules ont duré assez longtemps
entre des députés les républicains la
majorité continue à négocier aussi à la
pause au dîner les députés de la
majorité sont allés à Matignon autour
d'Élisabeth borne pour Contin à négocier
vous voyez ces discussions elles se font
au sein de la commission mixte paritaire
mais aussi dans les bureaux alentour
aussi à Matignon ici on ne s'ennuie pas
puisque des députés viennent nous
alimenter en information toutes les 20
toutes les 30 minutes et puis à chaque
suspension de séance évidemment merci
merci beaucoup Elsa pour toutes ces
explications on vous retrouve tout au
long de cette émission également avec
nous Quentin Calmet Quentin on le disait
les négociations elles ce son sont
enlisé en raison d'un désaccord et d'un
imbrogliot autour des aPL qu'en est-il
exactement
ouais effectivement th depuis 17h un
point bloc en particulier les aides au
logement leslr voulait et veulent
toujours les conditionner à plusieurs
années de présence sur le territoire à 5
ans en l'occurrence sauf que visiblement
cela ne faisait pas partie de l'accord
trouvé entre LR et Renaissance lors de
leur réunion à matigon d'où c un
brugliot effectivement et chaque camp
qui se renvoie la BAL les LR ont
expliqué ainsi à Public Sénat que quand
on a négocié c'était je cite très simple
toutes les prestations sociales non
contributives sont supprimées sauf la
loocation de compensation pour le
handicap on a toujours été clair disent
les LR du côté de renaissance plusieurs
députés sont venus donner leur version
du psychodrame ici même en salle des
quatre colonnes de l'Assemblée nationale
ils ne peuvent pas sortir un truc comme
cela à la dernière minute a dit ainsi
une députée Renaissance visiblement le
point est toujours sur la table et
chaque quand entre LR et Renaissance
renvoie la balle à l'autre et tient sur
sa ligne merci Quentin Calmet pour pour
ces précision alors Yanne brossa vous
vous êtes suppléant à cette commission
mixte paritaire ça veut dire que vous
étiez il y a quelques instants encore
dans cette salle de commission
dites-nous quelle est l'ambiance et
est-ce qu'un accord vous paraît possible
lors de cette réunion
je ne le sais pas à ce stade mais mon
sentiment général depuis d'ailleurs le
vote de la motion de rejet à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est que les macronistes sont
prêts à céder sur absolument tout à la
droite et en réalité minute après minute
heure après heure les Diges tombent les
unes après les autres enfin quand même
imaginez que les macronistes soient
prêts à voter cette disposition qui fait
qu'il faudra attendre 5 ans quand on est
en situation régulière j'y insiste pour
pouvoir toucher les prestations sociale
c'est quand même une évolution
proprement incroyable vous vous rendez
compte que au départ on nous parle d'un
texte qui visait à lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière qui visait à
faciliter par exemple l'expulsion de
délinquants sans papier et on en arrive
à une loi qui de fait va priver des gens
qui ce que vous nous dites c'est que
finalement c'est la version du du Sénat
quasiment dans son intégralité qui est
en train d'être reprise lors de cette
commission c'est à peu de choses près
c'est à peu de chose près le texte du
Sénat c'est-à-dire limitation du
regroupement familial limitation du
droit du sol suppression des allocations
familiales pour les gens dès lors qu'ils
sont en situation régulière mais depuis
moins de 5 ans sur le territoire
français bref c'est totalement la
version du du du Sénat mais vous savez
c'est pas très surprenant parce que les
macronistes au Sénat l'avaient
d'ailleurs voté bouigon est-ce que vous
êtes en train de céder sur toute la
ligne non mais je sais qu'il est tard et
que Monsieur brossa s'est probablement
Assou assoupi pendant cette commission
mixte paritaire et donc il lui a éch
que précisément si à ce stade il n'y a
pas d'accord dans la commission mixte
paritaire c'est précisément parce que
nous ne cédons pas sur les points dont
vous parlez nous ne cédons pas sur les
points dont vous parlez nous avons fixé
un certain nombre je vous a laissé
parler monsur que vous dit fa je sais
vous n pas trop la démocratie partiiste
mais dans un débat on laisse parler son
contradcto je vous ai laissé parler nous
avons fixé un certain nombre de lignes
rouges dans cette loi parce que nous
voulons une loi équilibrée voilà nous
voulons une loi qui permettent de
régulariser un certain nombre de
travailleurs dont nous avons besoin sur
les métiers en tension et nous voulons
qu'ils puissent bénificier précisément
des prestations parce que lorsque l'on
travaille on touche un salaire on cotise
et donc on a le droit à ces prestations
c'est notre ligne rouge et de l'autre
côté ce texte est équilibré parce que
nous renforçons un certain nombre de
dispositions qui nous permet d'expulser
ou de ne pas reconduire dans les titres
de séjour des personnes qui nous
paraissent avoir voir une attitude non
conforme aux valeurs de la République et
donc oui nous tenons la majorité
présidentielle sur une ligne équilibrée
sur les régularisations et sur les
expulsions et donc dans cette commission
mixte paritaire nous nous y sommes
entrés avec la volonté de dialoguer
parce que ce que les Français nous
demandent s'ils ont élu une Assemblée
nationale avec une majorité relative
c'est qu'ils veulent que nous puissions
discuter entre les groupes notamment
républicains et que nous puissions
dégager des consensus qui permett de
faire avancer la France et une immense
majorité des Français monsieur le
sénateur veut une loi sur l'immigration
veut que nous aboutisstions à une lois
sur l'immigration et c'est pourquoi nos
députés sont en train de négocier dans
cette commission mixte paritaire sont en
train de dialoguer pour essayer
d'aboutir et j'espère que les voix de la
raison de la sagesse l'emporteront à ce
texte qui va plus loin qui va dans la
bonne direction pour la France mais qui
est équilibré à la fois humaniste mais
également avec avec de l'autorité
Pierre-Henri Dumont euh on sait que la
commission mixte paritaire a été
suspendue pendant près de 4 heures à la
demande des républiain dites-nous
qu'est-ce qui bloque exactement chez
vous est-ce que il y a un désaccord
finalement est-ce que c'est pas tout à
fait les termes de l'accord qui était
prévu chez nous il y a pas Grand- chose
qui bloque en réalité nous avions dit
lors des discussions qui a pu y avoir
ces derniers jours avec le gouvernement
la première ministres les députés de de
la majorité euh que nous voulions avoir
un délai de carence euh c'està-dire un
nombre d'années nécessaires 5 ans pour
prendre l'exemple qui est celui que vous
avez utilisé pour pouvoir bénéficier
d'une allocation d non contributive
c'està-dire que une personne par exemple
qui a commencé qui est venue en France
qui a travaillé qui se retrouve au
chômage elle a cotiser pour pouvoir
bénéficier de son allocation chômage
donc elle pourrait le Touch a log pour
toucher par cont à côté il y a des
allocations que nous pouvons toucher
même si on n pas cotisé auparavant
doncon appelle des allocations non
contributives et dans le package il y a
ce qu'on connaît ce qui est évidemment
par exemple les allocations familiales
mais il y a aussi évidemment les APL et
évidemment que les Appl sont inclus
dedans puisque c'est 18 un budget de 18
milliards d'euros par an on a eu un
grand débat au début du précédent
quinquena d'ailleurs sur la question des
appels donc c'est évident que c'était
compris dedans et là c'est évident c'est
pas si évident que ça parce que
Renaissance
lu éé ça a toujours été à l'intérieur du
paacket ça a toujours été dit que dans
l'ensemble des allocations non
contributives il y a les appel
d'ailleurs pardon de le dire en droit
français quand vous regardez les
différents codes les APL sont liés à la
question des allocations familiales donc
on voit bien qu'on est sur les mêmes
choses on est sur les mêmes textes et
donc évidemment les deux sont liés que
la majorité est du mal que la majorité
doit faire un grand travail pour partir
de leur version initiale pour rejoindre
la version des républicains je l'entends
je l'entends c'est pas forcément facile
nous on a dû avaler énormément de coup
l'œuvre ces dernières années depuis 2017
mais c'est le jeu de la démocratie euh
mais vousêtes prê à tout faire capoter à
cause de cette mesure sur lesou nous
nous voulons nous nous voulons une CMP
conclusive nous voulons voter un texte
sur l'immigration parce que nous pensons
que la France a besoin d'un texte sur
l'immigration mais nous pensons que cela
doit passer aux conditions qui ont été
fixées étopé avec le gouvernement à
savoir que app pardon non et qui et qui
à partir du moment où on estime que les
allocations non contributive doivent
subir un délai de carence comme ça
existe déjà dans le droit le RSA il faut
avoir vécu 5 ans de façon légale en
France pour pouvoir le toucher donc on
nente pas un droit nouveau on met sur un
même pied d'égalité euh les allocations
familiales les APL avec le RSA ce qui
semble parfaitement normal et c'est ce
qui se passe d'ailleurs dans beaucoup
d'autres pays moi vous savez j'étais
étudiant à l'étranger quand j'étais
étudiant à l'étranger j'ai bénéficié
évidemment d'aucune aide j'ai même pas
le droit de travailler pour pouvoir
financer mes études quand j'étais à
l'étranger pour une année d'échange donc
ça se fait partout ailleurs même dans
des pays hyper ouverts à l'immigration
que ce soit le Canada que ce soit
l'Allemagne ça se passe comme ça alors
la Valette on s'approche d'une version
qui semblerait un peu plus durcie par
rapport à celle de de qui a été votée en
commission à l'Assemblée nationale
proche du Sénat euh finalement vous vous
étiez assez d'accord avec cette versionl
non je vous rappelle que nos sénateurs
n'ont pas voté le texte qui sorti du
Sénat donc je reviens 2 minutes sur sur
les APL et sur ses allocations je me
souviens de Marine Le Pen qui avait dit
c'est une petite loi mais on pourrait la
voter petite loi effectivement mais qui
c'est la quintessence du un même temps
vous avez quelques petites mesures de
fermeté des mesures administratives à
côté de ça vous avez encore des appels
d'air qui ne nous conviennent pas qui
sont des lignes rouges simplement pour
revenir sur ces allocations familiales
je me dire qu'elle se retrouve
maintenant au milieu de la CMP mais
quelle victoire pour ma famille
politique quelle victoire pour le
rassemblement national c'est une des
pierres angulaires évidemment de notre
programme cette priorité nationale que
ça soit aussi nous on la décline plus
loin pour l'emploi le logement vous
voyez et les allocations en famili
c'était même une pierre angulaire du
Front national donc je vais vous dire ce
soir je boutde pas mon plaisir de voir
que tout le monde revient à la raison on
avait donc raison sur les constats on
avait même raison sur les solutions donc
évidemment voilà sinon ce texte ne nous
suffit pas et nous nous l'avions dit
nous voulons passer par le référendum et
une révision constitutionnel parce que
nous pensons qu'il faut pour reprendre
en main cette politique migratoire
graver dans le marbre tous les outils
juridiques administratifs politiques qui
nous permettront vraiment de mettre le
code de la nationalité le code des
étrangers dans dans la Constitution et
je pense que il faut faut bien dire au
français de quoi l'on parle quand même
en France tous les ans rendent de façon
légale 500000 étrangers non c'est 320000
premier titre de séjour 136000 demandes
d'annonce demandes d'asile pardon c'est
il y a entre 400000 et 900000
clandestins les défis que pose cette
immigration massive sont énormes ils
sont économiques culturels sociaux et
sécuritaires les Français ont évidemment
bien fait le lien entre entre
l'insécurité qui arrivait dans leur pays
et cette cette immigration anarchique
démesurée donc nous pensons que ce texte
il est tout petit bras qu'il ne il n'est
pas du tout à la hauteur évidemment de
de l'enjeu mais c'est même pas moi qui
le dit c'est Monsieur shuttel ancien
secrétaire général du Conseil
constitutionnel voyez il a vraiment pas
sa sa carte au rassemblement national il
dit même que cette loi n'aurait pas
permis de d'expulser l'assassin de
Dominique Bernard donc vous voyez qu'on
est bien loin de protéger les Français
vous faire une belle démonstration alors
nous sommes également par téléphone avec
le président du groupe Union centriste
président de l'UD RV Marseille HERV
Marseille vous avez notamment bien
assisté à toutes les négociations qu'il
y a eu à Matignon depuis la semaine
dernière autour de ce texte est-ce que
vous avez l'impression et bien que on
s'approche tout de même d'un accord vous
voyez là et bien ce caillou des aPL qui
peut venir tout remettre en cause bah le
diable est dans le détail c'est c'est
voilà ces dernières 48 heur il y a eu
beaucoup de discussion beaucoup
d'amendements qui se sont échangés des
notes des des échanges verbaux et puis
quand on rentre dans le détail après on
tombe sur des ambiguïtés et chacun arg
de sa bonne foi en disant bah pour nous
c'était prévu il devit y avoir les APL
et d'autres disent bah non c'est pas
prévu et on peut pas en rester là bon
moi c'était pas prévu vous qui avez fait
toutes les discussions RV Marseille moi
je crois qu'-udelà de tout ça il y a une
obligation résultat parce que ça fait un
an qu'on discute de ce texte je suis pas
totalement convaincu que les Français
comprennent qu' en pleine nuit on
s'arrête sur un problème d'APL enfin je
veux dire aussi aussi important soit le
le sujet euh ça fait un an un an pile
qu'on discute de tout ça euh si on n'est
pas foutu dans un pays comme la France
de trouver une solution c'est qu'il y a
un problème institutionnel euh parce que
c'est pas l'affaire des appels qui peut
faire faire capoter un dossier comme
celui-là alors c'est quoi c'est qu'il y
a aussi la volonté de part et d'autrre
de pas vraiment s'entendre ou vous
parlez d'un problème institutionnel le
lequel serait-ce bah le problème
institutionnel on le connaît il n'y a
pas de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est le Sénat qui a pourvu les textes
que ce soit pour les retraites ou pour
l'immigration alors il faut trouver des
solutions à partir de ce texte bon euh
il peut y avoir un problème d'APL on
peut parler du dalallot on peut parler
d'un tas d'autres choses mais au bout
d'un moment il faut voter et je pense
que ce que les Français attendent c'est
un résultat c'est-à-dire un vote et qui
soit ratifié ensuite par l'Assemblée le
Sénat et parce que j'imagine mal que
demain matin on se réveille en disant
vous comprenez on s'est pas entendu sur
les ATL dans le texte c'est lunaire
Hervé Marseille l'accord qui semblait se
dessiner lors des discussions que vous
avez eu avec la première ministre euh
c'était un accord très proche de la
version du Sénat
oui il y a eu pas mal de
concessions sur le code de la
nationalité pour euh aller vers
l'Assemblée nationale il y a eu
également euh des concessions qui ont
été faites sur les délais pour la
naturalisation euh et et sur un certain
nombre d'autres points bon je crois
qu'on était proche de ce que souhaitait
l'Assemblée nationale dans sa diversité
puisque la la majorité comporte
plusieurs groupes et
donc maintenant on est en train de
s'apercevoir que l'écriture juridique
pose parfois des difficultés et entraîne
des conséquences qu'on avait pas
nécessairement merci RV Marseille merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous au cours
de cette émission en direct sur LCP et
Public Sénat on va retrouver Boris
Vallot le président du groupe PS qui
s'exprime des des aPL donc je ne saurais
pas vous dire où où on en est des
discussions entre les uns et et les
autres est-ce que vous avez sentiment
d'avancer écoutez ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que la majorité a cédé sur
toutes les lignes rouges et a désormais
dépassé les lignes bleu marines
reprenant à son compte en réalité tout
ce qu'elle avait combattu à la
commission des lois à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a une quinzaine de jours
puisque je rappelle à chaque article sur
lequel la majorité cède que le
rapporteur général le modem et le
président de la Commission avait le plus
souvent déposé des amendements de
suppression mais tout ça ne compte plus
dès lors qu'il s'agit d'établir une
caution pour les étudiants étranger
qu'il s'agit de rétablir le déli de
solidarité de livrer un hochet à travers
la promesse d'une proposition de loi sur
laame au début de l'année 2024 OLR en
réalité il cède il cède surtout oubliant
en réalité euh le en même temps pour
travailler sous les dicté de monsieur
sooti qui j'allais dire avec Monsieur
marlex hentre les couloirs comme des
ombres
voilà fait peur un peu voà pour cette
intervention de Boris valallot qui est
donc suppléant au sein de cette
commission mixte paritaire et tout de
suite également on va rejoindre Elsa
mondingava Elsa car et bien la
commission mixte paritaire a à nouveau
suspendu car on arrive à ce sujet
épineux dont on parle depuis maintenant
une quinzaine de minutes ce sujet des
aPL oui exactement on nous avait prévenu
qu'avant d'arriver à ce fameux article 1
N celui sur les APL et bien il allait
très certainement avoir une suspension
de séance on le voit c'est l'article la
décision qui cristallise les tensions la
majorité et la droite ont besoin et bien
de se voir pour s'entendre ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que normalement les
discussions elles se passent autour dans
cette commission mixte paritaire mais là
elle se passe aussi quand la commission
suspend ses travaux des discussions dans
les couloirs dans des bureaux il y a eu
des échanges aussi à Matignon à la pause
au déjeuner nous dans cette salle des
quatre colonnes là il y a les deux
députés par exemple du rassemblement
national qui sont en train de faire un
point avec les journalistes merci els
mondangava et on va retrouver tout de
suite edvich Diaz pour le rassemblement
national député de la Gironde qui
s'exprime qu'on se réjouit que ce texte
Prenn un nombre considérable de de
positions que nous défendons depuis
plusieurs années avec avec Marie le
considérer votre vote si les choses
continuent d'évoluer dans votre sens en
tout cas pour le
moment on peut constater qu'il y a quand
même quelques victoire idéologique pour
nous puisque effectivement les
conditions de regroupement familial bien
sont renforcées sont durcies et comme le
disait ma collègue le délit de séjour
irrégulier est rétabli pour autant il
reste des des points négatifs dans ce
texte aussi hein mais nous avons
quelques victoires
idéologiques tout le monde semble
confirmer et bien finalement que sur
certains thèmes liés à l'immigration
Marine Le Pen a raison depuis longtemps
et effectivement il y a encore quelques
semaines à peine c'était des mesures qui
étaient qui étaient fortement contbatttu
par nos adversaires et qui aujourd'hui
bah finalement sont plbicité où-ce qu'on
en est du débat sur les APL il est à
venir dans quelques minutes d'où la
suspension
ci donc vous pourriez au final peut-être
voter ce texte demain on est au début de
l'étude des articles pour le moment
encore beaucoup à dire il est trop tôt
pour se prononcerz
réun
d'hab autre réaction au micro d'Ava
Christophe député
oui coprésident du groupe lot c'est un
groupe sur lequel le gouvernement
comptait vous êtes suppléant dans cette
commission mixte paritaire quand vous
voyez évoluer le texte comment vous vos
députés vont se positionner à la fin
mais en fait nous ce qu'on a toujours
voulu c'est un texte qui soit équilibré
sans angélisme mais sans jusqu'au
bouhisme ce qu'il y a dans ce texte en
fin de compte c'est qu'on enlève
beaucoup de choses qui était
inconstitutionnel dans la version du
Sénat donc on va en fin de compte on
trouve quelque chose de beaucoup plus
cohérent alors certes pour l'instant sur
le titre a on est sur quelque chose d'un
peu plus dur que que ce qui était à la à
la commission ce qui est sorti de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
néanmoins pour l'instant on reste dans
quelques chose qui est dans le domaine
de l'acceptable pour vous sur ce débat
sur les APL est-ce qu'on peut attendre
30 mois de résidence 5 ans pour délivrer
ces APL ses aides personnalités au
logement aux étrangers en situation
régulière mais en fin de compte la
question est de se dire pourquoi est-ce
que les personnes viennent sur le
territoire et c'est pour ça qu'on
différencie les personnes qui
travaillent avec avec les personnes qui
ne travaillent pas et une fois qu'on a
dit ça c'est voir la situation exacte
des personnes donc en effet c'est un
sujet qui est extrêmement compliqué
d'ailleurs dans notre groupe ça a été un
réel une réelle discussion c'est est-ce
que c'est acceptable ou pas et c'est là
où il y a des divergences de vue suivant
les uns et les autres merci beaucoup
Christophe nen qu'on le rappelle si
cette commission mixte paritaire est
conclusive faudra qu'elle soit validée
par un vote en émisy deain ce qui pas
encore gagné merci el Mama François
Cormier bouon vous avez entendu Bor tout
à l'heure dire c'est un texte qui est
écrit sous la dictée d'éic sootti on a
entendu le rassemblement national dire
que c'est une victoire idéologique
est-ce que c'est la fin du et en même
temps est-ce que finalement Emmanuel
Macron est en train de se droitiser la
majorité avec je vais vous dire je vis
une situation de grande souffrance parce
que je rentre il y a à peine quelques
heures de Guyane où j'étais auprès des
forces militaires français qui défendent
cette belle collectivité d'outrem là-bas
et je reviens à Paris j'atterris
j'arrive au Palais Bourbon et je vois
cette vieille politique politicienne
assez médiocre avec un certain nombre
d'acteurs qui profèrent des
contrevérités mais vous êtes vous êtes
acteurs j'essaie de faire de la
politique noblement et là je vois des
gens qui ne savent proférer que des
mensonges si nous avions cédé si nous
avions cédé sur toute la ligne et bien
la commission sera déjà conclusive
depuis plusieurs heures et donc c'est
précisément parce que nous avons fixé
des lignes rouges sur des principes et
des valeurs républicaines qu'aujourd'hui
l'accord ne peut pas se faire madame la
valallette a fait une très belle
démonstration tout à l'heure oui le
rassemblement national c'est exactement
le Front national d'il y a 20 ou 30 ans
avec la préférence nationale avec toutes
avec toutes ces mesures qui sont un
espèce d'emballage à peu près acceptable
de ce qui ne l' pas c'est-à-dire du
racisme et donc ça nous nen voulons pas
et je vois je vois nos collègues des
opposition honnêtement vous avez voté
ensemble communiste écologiste insoumis
socialiste avec certains députés DLR une
motion de rejet pour aboutir à quoi pour
aboutir à un risque de texte qui risque
d'être durci si nous nous ne tenons pas
les lignes r vraiin est-ce que vouses
pas Laar roseur arrosé dans moi je
d'unot quand on travaille on cotise
on acquiert des droitsès et donc dro on
peut vous répondre pas être remis en
cause et moi je vous dis une chose je
termine làdus non mais je vous dis une
chose parce qu' il est minuit et donc
demain nous aurons peut-être un texte de
toute façon ce texte là s'il ne respecte
pas les lignes rouges que nous avons
définis et qui ont fait l'objet de
discussion ce weekend entre force
républicaines et bien nous serons un
certain nombre à ne pas la voter et donc
moi je dis à nos représentants dans la
CMP de ne pas céder s'ils veulent que ce
texte soit voté
demain si vous me permettez ne nous
faites pas croire que vous vous avez des
lignes rouges ça n'est pas vrai pour la
simple et bonne raison pour la simple et
bonne raison que le texte du Sénat vous
l'avez voté les sénateurs macroniste ont
voté le texte du S et si vous me
permettez d'en dire quelques mots ce
texte qui limite le regroupement
familial qui limite le droit du sol qui
supprime les allocations pour les gens
qui sont là depuis moins 5 ans c'est la
réalité c'est vrai donc vos lignes
rouges mon sentiment c'est qu'elles sont
écrites vous saz à l'encre sympathique à
peine écrite elles ont déjà disparu et
en réalité tous vos grands principes
princip il ne Val rien parce que vous
êtestalemé nationoind qutinal qui trouve
AC le président groupe les
indépendsil toutitour Claude maluret un
mot peut-être déjà sur l'ambiance en
commission mixte paritaire avec ces
heures de suspension comment est-ce que
vous avez vécu cela vous depuis votre
poste de suppléent ben écoutez c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas inhabituel
les suspensions que ce soit en
commission mix parétaire ou en
commission tout cours ça arrive lorsque
les groupes ont besoin de réfléchir à
quelque chose
d'imprévu manifestement les discussions
n'étaient pas encore terminé donc c'est
pas quelque chose qui entraîne des
crises de nerf chez les députés ou chez
les Sénateurs il y a un point
visiblement qui centralise beaucoup de
problèmes c'est la question des appels
les aides pour le logement comment
est-ce que vous comprenez tout ce yatus
autour de ce point précis c'est pas
parce que le point est plus important
que d'autres parce que tous les points
de cette loi sont importants c'est
simplement parce que dans les
discussions entre la première ministre
et certains groupes et notamment le
groupe des Républicains ce sujet a été
considéré comme abordé par les uns et
pas abordé par les autres parce comprat
entre les de camps euh parce que le
problème c'était de savoir si les appels
étaient considérés comme une prestation
sociale comme les autres ou quelque
chose de spécial les uns ont compris que
ça en faisait partie les autres ont
compris le contraire c'était une
discussion orale et le jour au moment où
elle été actée par écrit on s'est rendu
compte que la position divergeit très
franchement sur l'ensemble des 80
articles à peu près de cette loi il y a
27 articles mais au total il y en a
environ 80 c'est un sujet extrêmement
ponctuel si le débat ne pas porte
aujourd'hui à ce stade que sur celui-là
on va bien le voir dans dans courant de
la nuit mais si ça porte que sur
celui-là c'est quand même quelque chose
qui devrait se résoudre et donc pas de
quoi faire échouer la commission mixte
paritaire ce serait pas une ligne rouge
valable dans le camp Renaissance ou chez
leslr selon vous je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui peut être l'objet d'un
compromis comme beaucoup d'autres
articles ont été l'objet d'un compromis
d'un compromis sur la sur par exemple
sur la durée de présence pour bénéficier
des appel de la même façon que la durée
de présence pour bénéficier des
passations sociale donc on a trouvé un
compromis sur les prestations sociales
il y a pas de raison qu'on trouve pas
sur les APL maintenant à partir de là si
on en fait une posture politique bien
entendu on peut toujours trouver un
point mais à ce stade de la soirée je
pense plutôt je suis plutôt optimiste
sur le fait que ce point ne devrait pas
être un point de blocage une dernière
question si vous le voulez bien vous
avez parlé avec Madame born quand pour
la dernière fois estce que vous faites
partie de la majorité est-ce que vous
avez pu lui parler par exemple
aujourd'hui elle veut un accord jusqu'au
bout non moi j'ai participé à la réunion
d'hier soir je me rappelle plus quelle
heure il est si si on est
mardi ou lundi donc dimanche soir je nai
pas recontacté j'ai pas ni été
recontacté par Madame band mais bien sûr
qu'elle ve un accord bien sûr et bien
merci merci Claude maluret pour cette
réaction en direct au micro de publics
LCP merci Quentin Calmet Pierre-Henri
Dumont est-ce que les LR sont en
position de force là et comment vous
allez comment vous espérez transformer
l'essai écoutez ce qu'on est en position
de force il y a une réalité mathématique
la majorité sénatoriale plus le
représentant en CMP c'est 5 personnes
pour les républicains et le centre la
majorité sont C également donc çaà dire
qu'il y a 10 voix sur 14 qui sont au
sein des républicains de la majorité
donc le deal ne peut se faire s'il y a
une CMP conclusive que mathématiquement
entre les républicains
et et la majorité présidentielle en
position de force aussi parce que le
texte qui sur lequel nous travaillons
c'est le texte du Sénat parce que c'est
le seul texte qui a été voté et donc on
a en CMP une discussion noralement qui
vise à joindre deux textes sauf que là
il y a un texte d'à côté qui est le
texte des républicains avec de l'autre
côté une page blanche donc évidemment
que on est en train de parler d'abord
sur la base du texte des républicains
donc ça veut pas dire parce qu'on est en
position de force que nous devons être
en position hégémonieque nous devons
être fermés à la discussion à négciation
ça ve dire que vous n'allez rien faire
éventuellement CRE victoire c'està
direire que non attendez moi je je comme
on disait sous Chirak c'est à la fin de
la foire qu'on compte les bouses hein
donc attendons d'abord d'avoir une CMP
conclusive moi j'ai comme le président
maluré j'ai plutôt confiance dans la
capacité des différents représentants en
tout cas des 10 qui sont capables de
pouvoir trouver un accord au sein de la
commission mixte paritaire sur les 14 de
trouver cet accord que demain il soit
voté et au Sénat ça devrait pas poser
trop de problème et à l'Assemblée
national parce que je vous le dis une
fois plus les Français ont besoin d'un
texte le pays a besoin d'un texte pour
mieux expulser mieux int mais est-ce que
vous avez envie de peser sur d'autres
texte à l'avenir comme vous avez sû ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a
bien compris que l'EN même temps était
mort voilà et que la stratégie du du
président de la République qui viser
lors de ce texte à repousser les
amendements de droite en discussion
publique grâce à l'aide de laanupess à
repousser repousser les amendements de
gauche en séance publique grâce à l'aide
de la droite et du rassemblement
national c'est une stratégie qui a
échoué et que ça va forcément nécessiter
une redéfinition une discussion non pas
une alliance non pas un accord de
gouvernement mais en tout cas que la
majorité comprennent que après 18 mois
il sera peut-être temps qui sont non pas
en majorité absolue mais en majorité
extrêmement relative et qui sont soumis
à la discussion et que la discussion
c'est pas quelque chose de mauvais en
démocratie alors nous sommes également
en visio avec Valérie Boyer sinatrice
les républicain des bouches du rô
bonsoir Valérie Boyer vous entendez bien
votre collègueir de l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que vous estimez que et
bien il peut se dessiner alors peut-être
pas forcément une alliance mais en tout
cas une relaction de proximité sur le
reste du quinquena avec Renaissance
quand vous voyez comme c'est en train de
se passer sur ce texte vous savez nous
ce qui nous importe c'est d'être
efficace et nous souhaitons un texte qui
soit efficace pour répondre aux besoins
des Français euh c'est chikaya
aujourd'hui je les trouve un petit peu
dépassé d'autant que en ce qui concerne
les républicains la plupart des des
sujets qui sont venus sur la table et
même des discussions aujourd'hui
notamment sur le conditionnement des
allocations non
contributive à un délai de séjour
c'était dans le programme de Valérie PCR
donc on l'avait déjà on l'avait déjà mis
ce que je voudrais que les Français a
bien en perspective ce soir c'est que là
nous nous enfin j'espère que la la CMP
sera conclusive parce que les Français
ont besoin d'un texte sur l'immigration
mais je ne perd pas de vue que il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir un référendum et
qu'il est nécessaire de revenir sur les
traités internationaux aujourd'hui en
terme d'immigration et c'est ce que nous
avons toujours dit et c'est la raison
pour laquelle les républicains ont
déposé un même texte à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat et que aujourd'hui
concernant le point qui fait blocage sur
sur les APL je rappelle que les
allocations non contributif comprennent
les allocations familiales laallocation
logement laallocation handicapée et que
ça avait été voté au Sénat qu'
aujourd'hui il y a eu un consensus sur
le handicap mais que franchement ce
serait vraiment dommage comp tenu des
attentes des Français qui s'exprime
sondage après sondage que sur la loi
ordinaire on narrive pas à trouver un
accord ça me semblerait totalement
extravagant et là moi je suis très
optimiste enfin très optimiste en
j'espère vraiment qu'on va
avirte par que c'est ceattendent les
Français et les propositions qui ont été
voté au Sénat correspondent sondage
après sondage aux attentes des Français
ils l'ont encore exprimé dans un Grand
Journal du
Dimanche hier et je crois que ce serait
pas responsable que le gouvernement ne
trouve pas les voies nécessaires pour
enfin la majorité présidentielle ne
parvenir à à donner un TEX texte au
français un texte qu'ils attendent pas
des des considérations
politico-politiciennes qui a gagné qui a
perdu nous ce que nous souhaitons c'est
de l'efficacité il y a trop de
souffrance lié à l'immigration une
souffrance pour les Français une
souffrance pour les migrants puisque
nous nintégr pas bien on sait
parfaitement que la plupart des migrants
illégaux qui viennent ils viennent parce
qu'ils sont aux mains de trafiquant
d'êtres humains regardez je vous prendre
un exemple sur le trafic d'êtres humains
depuis la loi colon moi j'avais fait
partie de ceux et à l'époque
Pierre-Henri Dumont était jeune député
c'était son premier mandat je crois
j'avais voté j'avais demandé sous la loi
colon donc 1 si je puis dire à ce qu'on
criminalise les passeurs à l'époque j'ai
été moqué dans l'hémicycle pour cet
amendement aujourd'hui c'est une
nécessité absolue de faire en sorte que
les peurs soient criminalisés donc merci
beaucoup Valérie Boyet d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur LCP et sur Public
Sénat dans cette émission spéciale Yan
brossa on entend Valérie Boyet qui
disent les français demandent ce texte
sur l'immigration on voit même que dans
l'électorat de gauche il y a une demande
de plus de de fermeté est-ce que c'est
pas une défaite idéologique de la gauche
non mais qu'un pays ait des frontières
et décide de qui a le droit d'entrer sur
son territoire et qui n'a pas le droit
de le faire c'est une évidence qu'on ait
par ailleurs besoin dans un certain
nombre de cas d'éloigner des gens du
territoire français quand ils sont
dangereux c'est une évidence aussi ce
que je regrette c'est qu'on soit parti
de ça pour arriver par exemple à la
suppression des allocations familiales
pour des gens qui je le redis sont en
situation régulière ne posent aucun
problème et vont devoir attendre 5 ans
avant d'avoir la possibilité de toucher
des prestations sociales mais vous savez
que la droite défimigration était quand
même nécessaire oui en tout cas qu'on
ait besoin d'un certain nombre de
dispositions sur le sujet ne me choque
absolument pas simplement que la droite
défende les positions de la droite c'est
normal que le rassemblement national
défende les positions du rassemblement
national c'est normal que la macronie
donne une victoire idéologique au
rassemblement national en reprenant les
propositions du Front national des
années 80 excusez-moi de vous le dire
mais ça me choque profondément et que
ces gens ne nous fassent pas croire
qu'ils défendent une position équilibrée
et le fameux en même temps de gauche et
de droite ils ne sont plus en même temps
de gauche et de droite ils sont en même
temps de droite et d'extrême droite et
ils viennent d'une certaine manière de
le révéler aujourd'hui écoutez ce que
disent les députés du rassemblement
national qui disent merci à la macronie
de leur avoir permis d'arracher cette
victoire idéologique quand même quand
même ça devrait poser et Merci à VOUS
Yan brossa d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci beaucoup on va retrouver Daniel
auono à présent député la France
insoumise de Paris qui est au micro de
Stéphanie des pierres salle des quatre
colonnes Daniel obono vous assisté
depuis plusieurs heures à cette
commission mixte paritaire les les
discussions se déroulent surtout entre
les républicains et le camp présidentiel
vous êtes un
peu non parce que nous ne cessons de
rappeler à quel point désormais euh la
macronie se le pénise et vous avez
notamment le président de la commission
des lois le rapporteur monsieur Houlier
et bouer qui n'en finissent pas d'avaler
des coup l'œuvres puisqu'il se retrouve
à défendre des amendements qu'ils
avaient dont ils avaient demandé la
suppression en commission des lois et
donc le Ren à beau jeu de se réjouir
article après article du fait que la
macronie est en train là d'appliquer des
mesures de de Madame Le Pen j'aimerais
juste rappeler aussi le fait que ces
mesures qui en lève des droits qui
précaris qui vulnérabilise les personnes
étrangères ne vont rien apporter aux
Français et aux Françaises là la
commission mixte parallèle qui donc se
déroule en même temps que la commission
mixte paritaire officielle cette
commission mixte parallèle entre
l'exécutif et l'ELR est en train de
négocier par exemple les allocations
retirer des allocations étendre le délai
avant lesquel les personnes étrangères
puissent y avoir droit mais que les
Français et les Françaises n'imaginent
pas que cela va signifier pour les
Français et les Françaises plus
d'allocation non ça c'est moins de droit
pour tout le monde et donc nous nous
sommes présents et présentes dans cette
commission pour rappeler euh toutes les
compromissions que fait la macronie et
vous euh saurez peut-être que beaucoup
se taisent et n'osent pas revendiquer
euh toute tous les méfait qu'ils sont en
train de de commettre parce qu'ils
savent bien que là ils sont en train
d'appliquer le programme de l'extrême
droite merci
beaucoup merci Stéphanie des piierr et
on accueille Cyriel châelin présidente
du groupe les écologistes qui nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau lors La Vallette
on entendait et bien le la France
insoumise qui dit à nouveau combien ce
taexe va sur votre terrain encore une
fois on ne comprend pas très bien
pourquoi est-ce que vous ne pourriez pas
le voter je vous l'ai dit ce texte il
est petit bras c'est pas lui qui va
évidemment solutionner le problème de de
l'immigration et sur ce plateau on est
quand même tous démocrates on est tous
on a tous la même légitimité mais je
vais vous l simplement les chiffres du
sondage ilab qui est sorti la semaine
dernière 68 % des Français sont pour la
suppression de la me 72 % sont pour
changer la constitution 74 % sont pour
la fin du sol 81 % sont pour rétablir le
délit de séjour illégale 85 % sont pour
la double peine donc en fait cette
victoire idéologique cette adhésion
c'est le peuple français non c'est là
vous voyez monsieur c'est BFM TV donc
vous voyez voilà donc en fait vous
pouvez continuer à creuser un trou à à
mettre votre tête dedans et à faire
l'autruche mais la quasi totalité de la
délinquence de rue est du à des étrang
93 % des délits dans les transports
publics en Île-de-France sont dus à des
étrangers 63 % des violences sexuelles
sont dus à des étrangers alors moi je
veux bien on peut faire comme si tout
allait bien et comme s'il y avait aucun
lien entre l'immigration et la sécurité
mais% viol se
qui son défér devant parquet de Paris
son des murs son
vit vous nous fait
desptif vousavez vé vous n'avez voté
aucune loi renforçant la police vous
navez vous navez voté aucune loi
renfor vouz pas voter
laimig vérité c'est vous êtes des
grandux et vous êtes des
PE quand Arve quand il vous arrive
Madame La Valette d'être au pouvoir dans
d'autres pays par exemple madame bon en
Italie en disant ce que vous dites et à
la fin elle s'apprête à régulariser
500000 migrants mais j'ai bien compris
madame j'ai bien compris que Madame mon
n pas votre allié puisque votre allié
c'est Salvini c'estàd celui qui est
encore plus à l'trme dro réduit
drastiquementigra Chatelin alors
attendez parce que là vous êtes en train
de faire un monologue chacun de votre
côté ch est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que c'est un texte qui est
teinté de de la couleur du RN en tout
cas moi je suis atérée par le débat
enfin je suis désolée c'estd que votre
argument c'est regardez on est aussi
enfin je suis désolé on va aussi loin on
estussi extrême que vous mais en plus on
va le faire on agit contre la
délinquence agit contre ce qui at VUR de
rép la paroley faudrait mettre face face
à cesad trouve quand on a le bilan de
Monsieur Darmanin excusez-moi mais il
faut s'arrêter 2 minutes quand on a le
plus faible taux d'octf de ces dernières
décennies vous pouvez pas arriver en
nous disant que vous avez envie de
résoudre le problème de l'immigration et
de l'insécurité vous plaisantez c'est
votre bilan 5 IMR c'est votre bil av
évité des dizaines d'attentats sur le
territoire
in réj vous réjou de comme d'habit vous
vous réjouissez du malheur des autres
nous avons évité des dizaines
d'attentats parce que non pas du tout
nous faisons preuve d'autorité mais
également
d'humanisme Monop Paro du coup est- que
vous pouvez finir votre propos oui je
crois que on a une nouvelle illustration
enfin je suis désolé chers collègues
mais à force de courir après l'extrême
droite per
plus fort par ça enc plus convant allez
j'aiun problème avec
ça
désolua la parole est- qu'on pe lu
laisser
la leexte tous les deux en étant alli
donc voilà c'est quoi d'ailleurs la
position de
Géral sais vous êes OBD paral élargir un
peu le déb première chose vous avez cité
le le sondage etable pour BFM TV il est
assez intéressant effectivement 69 % des
Français sont favorables à une loi mais
ils sont favorables à une loi équilibrée
c'est-à-dire qui peut être dur mais qui
sait aussi soutenir les personnes qui
viennent construire leur vie dans le
dans notre pays qui viennent travailler
lever leurs enfants et en fait toute
cette parti là il a disparu du texte
c'estàdire que vous avez capitulé parce
si vous avez capitulé face au
Républicain vous avez et qui s'inspire
malheureusement du programme du
rassemblement national il y a toujours
des régularisations pour les
travailleurs là pour le moment on n'est
pas encore arrivé au 4 bis hein donc on
va attendre voir dans quel état ça va ça
va arriver et si c'est la version du
Sénat ce n'est pas une régularisation
enfin faut arrêter une régularisation à
la main du préfet c'est ce qui était
prévu par le Sénat vous estimez que ce
n'est pas suffisant non parce qu'on
devait avoir une régularisation des
personnes qui travaillent des personnes
qui travaillent qui justeement sont AR
illégalement sur notre se madame chatin
il faut le dire quand même oui mais en
fait non mais c'est absolument V que a
aussi une incohérence absolue vousiez
que la plupart des des clandestins en
France n'arrivent pas de façon
clandestinear de façon régulière
m vous dites en
disant m so vous avez dit la grande
majorité les clandesttin pour
l'écrasante majorité arrivent de façon
légale et se maintienent de façon
irrégulière c'est pour ça que les
républicains au Sénat ont demandait par
exemple sur les étudiants parce que
c'est la première source d'immigration
légale dans notre pays d'avoir une
caution pour s'assurer que les étudiants
qui veulent étudier en France puissent
ensuite repartir dans leur pays grâce au
système de cautionnement allez on va
repartir sal des quatre colonnes où se
trouve Elsa mondingava Elsa vous êtes
avec Louis Marguerite il est député
renaissance de sonéloire oui et vous
avez entendu le RN se satisfait de voir
la majorité reprendre certaines de ces
mesures qu'est-ce que vous ça vous fait
au sein de la majorité n'avez-vous pas
peur de faire trop de concession dans
cette CMP non pas du tout c'est une
posture totalement scandaleuse ils
invoquent la préférence nationale qui
est pour nous une ligne rouge absolue et
c'est d'ailleurs nos négociateurs qui le
font pour le groupe Renaissance et pour
la majorité tiennent cette ligne nous
nous sommes pour privilégier le travail
et nous l'avons dit et effectivement
c'est un point important il y aura cette
discussion éidement sur les APL il
faudra trouver le le bon point
d'équilibre je rappelle quand même que
il y a déjà des conditions sur les
prestations non contributives notamment
sur le RSA qui qui n'est autorisé qu'à
partir de
présen sur le territoire donc encore une
fois un ce n'est pas nouveau et deux la
préférence nation c'est évidemment une
ligne rouge pour nous est-ce que vous
comprenez que là les tensions se
cristallisent autour de cette question
des aPL mais c'est c'est on est sur un
texte qui est évidemment important sur
on regarde ligne à ligne et c'est normal
qu'il a un peu de cristallisation c'est
une négociation qui n'est pas simple sur
lequel chacun a ses lignes rouges chacun
donne une concession à l'autre et
évidemment on essaie de trouver le point
d'équilibre donc c'est pas anormal qu'il
a de la discussion c'est normal qu'
qu'elle nécessite un peu de un peu de
temps et donc c'est ce que nous en
sommes en train de vivre ce soir allez
on va pas faire les Paris mais pour vous
elle peut être conclusive cette
commission mixte paritaire moi je suis
raisonnablement optimiste sur notre
capacité à obtenir à obtenir ce texte
d'abord parce que les Français
s'intéressent pas du tout à ce qui se
passe en ce moment même ce soir ça c'est
vraiment le le jeu politicien d'ailleurs
pas forcément très toujours très beau à
voir en revanche ils attendent un texte
c'est qu'on bouge sur cette question
parce que l'opinion publique plébiscite
le besoin d'un texte pour être
effectivement plus dur sur l'immigration
irrégulière plus dur avec ceux qui n'ont
rien à faire sur notre territoire
national et en revanche qui facilite un
certain nombre d'intégration et c'est ce
que nous souhaitons porter merci
beaucoup Louis Marguerite
raisonnablement optimiste merci merci
beaucoup ela qu'est-ce que vous inspire
cal châelin ce débat autour des aides
pour le logement les appels qui on le
voit sont devenus la pomme de discord
sur ce début de ce texte je trouve que
c'est le parfait exemple de la
capitulation dont je parlais c'està-dire
que non mais le propos finit par nous
voulons que les personnes qui sont là
pour travailler et construire leur vie
puissent vivre et s'intégrer comment
est-ce que vous voulez faire si pendant
alors que vous travaillez pendant 30
mois voire 5 ans parce qu'on a toujours
pas le texte vous n'avez pas les appel
mais mais c'est une vraie question c'est
c'est en mettant les personnes dans une
précarité économique totale que vous
allez leur permettre de s'intégrer s
leur coupant les allocations familiales
alors qu'ils travaillent c'est moi je ne
comprends pas aujourd'hui comment ce
texte là qui est censé donner aussi de
la sécurité à des personnes qui viennent
dans notre pays légalement qui pour
certaines ont travaillé ont perdu leur
titre de séjour effectivement continue à
travailler et en fait d'un coup quand
ils retrouvent un titre de séjour ils
auront plus le droit à rien enfin moi je
trouve ça absolument alors dans la
majorité vous tenez à ce que les APL
puissent demeurer pour les personnes qui
arrivent sur le territoire français il y
a aussi les allocation familiale enfin
non mais là on prend les appels mais Mme
rou est-ce que c'est une ligne rouge
est-ce que vous allez tenir làdessus
nous souhaitons tenir là-dessus vous
avez cédé sur les allocations
familialesin non si les allocations
aujourd'hui les allocations famili des
question déignz que nous puissions
répondre elle a raison sur ce non mais
c'est mais oui mais je préère qu vous
dites la vérité
vous parlez de capitulation s'il y avait
eu capitulation la CMP serait conclusive
depuis maintenant plusieurs heures or
elle ne l'est pas donc votre argument
est une contrevérité de pour il y a eu 3
He deuxè le point principal sur ce volet
humain c'est l'intégration par le
travail et donc nous nous souhaitons que
ce texte est une jambe euh sociale
humaine qui permettent à ces
travailleurs d'être régularisés parce
qu'ils occupent des emplois dont notre
société a besoin et sur ce texte nous
portons une conviction c'est que cette
demande doit être à la main euh du de
celui qui travaille du travailleur et
non pas à la main de son employeur et
donc dans le texte que nous défendons et
à la main du préfet est-ce que la
version du Sénat ça vous dans le texte
que nous défendons euh le demandeur
celui qui travaille et qui veut être
régularisé pourra faire la preuve par
tout moyen de la réalité de son emploi
d'autres défendent une autre version
c'est-à-dire que c'est à l'employeur de
demander c'est à l'employeur de prouver
la réalité de l'emploi nous nous voulons
au contraire que ce soit la main du
salarié et que le préfet décide en toute
l'égalité de la régularisation vous avez
changé puisque vous vous soutiez au
départ que ce soit une régularisation
automatique mais nous sommes dans un
dialogueui
on veulent que nous débattions que nous
travaillons ensemble discution et que N
et que nous parvenions à un texte qui
les protège oui euh mais pas en étant
mais pas en étant des beauparleurs en
étant des responsables qui agissont
c'est ce que nous fa oui et ça fait 6
ans que nous avons des beaucoup de
résultats pour notre pays et donc là en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence dans chaque
entreprise moi je il suffit pas de dire
les choses pour que ce soit vra comment
ça va protéger les Français mais comment
ça va protéger les Français vousz
monopole du député je vais dans mes
entrepris et comment ça va protéger les
Français si on pourra pas régulariser
les personnes qui sont a toutes les
entrees pardon toutes les entreprises
cherchent des salariés toutes à bourge
et dans le Cher Nord et partout en
France donc nous devons un permettre au
demandeurs d'emploi d'être formé pour
occuper ses emplois de pouvoir
régulariser ce c'est ce que nous allons
faire nous allons poursuivre les
circulaires V et nous allons circulair
pour pouvoir régulariser ça on a bien
compris r les aides au logement est-ce
que c'est une ligne rou rép
une ligne rou parti du texte au Sénat
mais pour une raison qui est très simple
c'est qu'on a une vision différente de
l'immigration que la majorité et que la
gauche des allocations où on pense que
d'abord quand on vient en France le
premier droit qu'on a CELI de toucher d'
allocation bah c'est pas ce qu'on pense
à droite pardon nous ce qu'on pense à
droite c'est que il faut qu'on passe
d'une immigration qui aujourd'hui est
d'abord familiale la plupart des stocks
de titre de séjour c'est de
l'immigration familiale regroupement
familial famille de français et cetera
et cetera qui est sousqualifié 40 % des
immigré en France un niveau brevet des
collèges ou inférieur quand c'est 18 %
en population générale 51 % des arrivés
en 2021 un diplôme de l' je vousi jamais
interrompu madame parole à votre tour
oui mais je vous donne juste un fait 51
% des arrivés en 2021 diplôme de
l'enseignement supérieur et donc je vous
dis que aujourd'hui les CHR aujourd'hui
40 % de la population immigré ont un
niveau brevet des collè 51 % des arrivés
en
2021 vous croyez vraiment que lesrés
viennent parce qu' a des alloc j'ai
absolument pas dit ça je dis juste que
nous voulons réorienter l'immigration
qui est aujourd'hui familiale subie
sousqualifié vers une immigration de
travail surqualifié et choisi et donc
pour cela il faut aussi mettre des des
des incitations à oui prendre des
travail mais aussi à prendre des
étrangers d'où le développement des
passeports talents qu'on avait
accompagné qui était une bonne mesure du
projet de loi colon une des rares qui a
été mise en avant également dans ce
texte pour avoir des personnes
étrangères qui sont surqualifié qui
peuvent permettre d'encadrer des
Français ou des étrangers déjà présents
en France sur des jobs qui sont eux
moins qualifiés parce que la réalité
c'est quoi c'est que on a aujourd'hui
dans les métiers dit en tension c'est
pour ça qu'on avait un vrai problème sur
l'article 3 qui est devenu l'article 4
bis qui était que on a des étrangers
clandestins dans les métiers en tenstion
qui sont utilisés comme de la chair à
canon par certains patrons qui ont aucun
scrupule d'ailleurs le rassemblement
national avait mis un amendement pour ne
pas poursuivre les patrons V pour ne pas
poursuivre les pour ne pas poursuivre
les patrons qui empoyé des clandest la
parole
expliquer et donc nous ce que l'on veut
c'est que oui en effet je trouve que
c'est plutôt une bonne mesure que les
personnes qui sont restés bah ceux qui
savent lire pardon il suffit juste
d'aller sur internet et de voir votre
hypocrisie Madame La Valette et donc on
est face à cette situation où il y a
aujourd'hui des employeurs qui utilisent
des clandestins pour ne pas augmenter
les salaires pour ne pas améliorer les
conditions de travail dans les métiers
les moins qualifiés qui à côté de ça
font en sorte de ne pas régulariser les
clandestins et donc on est aujourd'hui
dans cette situation il faut absolument
verrouiller les
réularisation et le C bis le C bis on a
prévu et on est nous députés les
républiquain sur la base du cadbis à le
verrouiller encore plus faire en sorte
que ce soit absolument pas possible de
faire appel et d'aller en justice
si une régularisation sur l'amendement
de li Pino et vous savez très bien la
mauvaise foi à laquelle vous faites
appel c'est
simplement la charge de la preuve de de
la régularité des papiers était
transféré au prestataire
travx dans
V faites des travaux dans votre maison
vous embchez à couvreur si le couvreur
EMB des
g vous avez très bien compris qu'en fait
la charge de la preuve était au
prestataire et non pas au petit patron
c'était simplement tous les trour de la
TOS famill politiqu on PL la France dans
marasme et le chaos migrationniste dans
lequel nous sommes mais
oui qu colonnes où se trouve Stéphanie
des piier Stéphanie vous nous entendez
alors il y a plusieurs options possibles
ce soir on sait que la CMP n'est pas
toujours conclusive al il y a beaucoup
de bruit ici sur ce plateau la CMP est
toujours réunie il y a toujours pas
d'accord là c'est suspendu toujours pas
d'accord alors quelles sont les les
options possibles Stéphanie alors la
Réunion est toujours suspendue est-ce
qu'elle va reprendre pour l'instant on
ne sait pas toutes les options sont sur
la table continuer la discussion
jusqu'au bout de la nuit peut-être
s'arrêter et reprendre demain matin en
tout cas le point d'achopement c'est
toujours la question des allocations
logement les troupes présidentiel et les
députés les républicains en discutent à
ce moment même mais tout le monde
réaffirme sa position les républicains
redisent qu'ils ne que c'est un point
sur lequel ils ne cèderont pas il y a
une demi-heure des députés renaissan
sont venus redire que eux non plus ne
céderaiit pas on ne voit pas très bien
pour l'instant comment on sort de
l'ornière et comment on arrive à un
accord merci merci beaucoup Stéphanie
syyriia Chatelin comment est-ce que vous
qualifieriez la situation dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons est-ce qu'on est dans
un moment où il y a eu une péripétie
parlementaire est-ce que ça tourne à la
crise politique aujourd'hui à la crise
de régime on en est où non je pense
qu'on est dans un moment de
clarification politique en 2017 Emmanuel
Macron était élu avec une promesse qui
était ni droite ni gauche ben en fait
aujourd'hui cette promesse est morte
c'estàdire que nous avons une famille
politique qui perd son ADN et qui juste
adopte un texte qui est le texte de
droite elle retrouve finalement son
espace naturel qui est l'espace de la
droite et de la
droite radicalisé ce qui moi m'inquiète
énormément et je voudrais quand même
revenir rapidement sur ce qui a été
dit mélchon qui nous parlait de
radicalisation soyez oui nous avons une
une alliance sur un programme sur des
projets sur
nous au moins on fait du barrage c'est
tout à fait on assume le barrage on
assume le barrage républain que vous
vous n'assumez pasis je vis quand même
revenir sur sur quand même la vision de
travail qui était assez intéressant le
débat qu'on avait sur les chiffres était
assez intéressant c'estd qu'en fait
finalement ce texte parce que vous avz
vous nous expliquez aujourd'hui la part
d'immigré le taux de
de de niveau de de diplôme moi je
expliqué que les personnes qui
arrivaient étaient bien plus diplômé
c'est qu'aujourd'hui en 2021 chif sa 51
% des personnes qui arrivent ont un
diplôme de l'enseignement supérieur vous
allez que dire non mais aujourd'hui les
personnes sont pas diplômées et bien
c'est ça cette loi elle va aujourd'hui
dégrader la vie des personnes qui sont
déjà ici qui sont déjà en France qui
travaillent en France qui élèvent leurs
personnes leurs enfants en France en
fait elles vont elle va dégrader la vie
de nos voisins et alors qu'aujourd'hui
et elle va en plus je pense sur les
personnes qui arrivent notamment les
étudiants elle va les décourager de
venir c'est que moi je suis élu d'une
circonscription où il y a un centre
universitaire Grenble où il y a des
entreprises qui après vont travailler
avec ces étudiants et en fait on va leur
dire quoi ne venez plus étudier en
France objectif Pier hen Dumont mais
pardon mais ça absolument rien à voir
avec la question de décourager les
étudiant ou pas la le
r la caution il la récupère à la fin
donc en quoi ça pose un sujet quand vous
allez dans n'importe quel autre pays du
monde madame vous allez dans n'importe
quel autre pays du monde vous navez pas
d' vous allez dans n'importe quel autre
pays du monde pour étudier vous vous
payez l'université plein pot la France
est le pays pour les étudiants étrangers
qui est le plus accueillant qu'on
s'assure mais mais c'est pas un problème
mais qu'on s'assure que l'étudiant qui
est venu étudier en France qui doit
repartir pour une raisons ex grec parce
que on estime qu'on a pas besoin de sa
compétence parce qu'il a du travail chez
lui parce qu'il doit développer son pays
et ben qu'il reparte ça semble
parfaitement cohérent et comme on vous
l'a dit tout à l'heure la principale
source d'immigration illégale et de
création de clandestinité c'est
l'immigration légale et donc c'est en
parul l'immigrationudante on l'a vu
malheureusement dans divers d'horribl
fait divers où ce sont personnes qui
étaient venu sous le titre étudiants qui
sont restés en France sont mainten dans
l'illégalité et
quiis
atrocitésation qui nous vient la salle
desones trouve Stéphanie des PI
Stéphanie la séance est suspendue en
commission mixte paritaire et ça prendre
tout de suite oui on vient de laap
prendre Brigitte la réunion de la
commission mixte paritaire est suspendue
et elle ne devrait reprendre que demain
matin à 10h et demi vous le savez les
négociations durent depuis plusieurs
heures et pour l'instant ça n'avance pas
il y a toujours ce point d'achopement
sur les allocations logements entre le
camp présidentiel et les républicains
les deux camps ont réaffirmé leur
position il y a encore quelques minutes
on voyait pas très bien comment on
pouvait arriver à un accord et bien ils
ont semble-t-il décidé que la nuit
porterait conseil décidé donc de
suspendre la la réunion le président de
la commission mixte paritaire Sacha
Houlier député Renaissance vient de
l'annoncer les débats les discussions de
cette commission reprendront donc demain
matin vers 10h30 bonne nuit oui un mot
de conclusion c'est donc pas gagner en
tout cas pour avoir une commission mixte
paritaire adopté en séance demain comme
c'était prévu en tous les cas vous le
voyez nous sommes prêts à continuer les
discussions pour aboutir un texte madame
châelin vous voulez mettre fin madame
châelin vous voulez mettre fin au
travail clandestin qui tire les salaires
vers le bas nous le voulons aussi en
régularisant les travailleurs travaillez
avec nous et voter ce texte pierrehenri
Dumont vous voulez une
véritableel moment vous avez discuté
avec nous non mais ça m'intéresse à quel
moment vous avez discuté ensemble nous
pouvions faire la majorité à la et bien
moi je vous tends la main voez ce texte
trouvons un accord pour voter ce texte
nous parv c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous tous d'avoir été avec nous
et d'être venu débattre en plateau pour
cette émission spécial LCP Public Sénat
merci th merci Brigitte et la réunion de
la commission mixte paritaire reprendra
donc demain à 10h30 alors que le débat
se poursuit en plateau très bonne soirée
sur les chaînes
[Musique]
parlementaires